[Music]
on TV on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
TV tonight on PE Morgan un sensored it
was two weeks ago that I interviewed
Bassam USF the Egyptian comedian and
political commentator dealing with
Israel is so difficult it's like being
in a relationship with a narcissistic
psychopath and that interview became the
biggest in our show's history with more
than 20 million people so far watching
it I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your questions so we decided to
sit down again and this time here in Los
Angeles where Bassam lives because of
our interview I sold out Arizona really
yes and we talked for nearly 2 hours
about the Israel Palestine War about the
75e conflict this was basically pushed
on us by the Europeans and it was a
fascinating it's not about Hamas anymore
it is not about H they can tell you it's
about challenging no they didn't though
num they didn't numbers that's not true
and revealing conversation all roads in
this crisis lead to Hamas and what they
did and and not necessarily because
because all roads goes to the condition
that
[Music]
created well basson Piers it's good to
see you it's good to see you to um last
time obviously we did it remotely yes
you were here I was in London and you
complained that it was an unfair situ
situation you couldn't see me your
earpiece kept falling out yes so I
thought okay fair enough I hear you I
got on a plane I flew 6 and half
thousand miles and not only that we're
doing it in somewhere that is very
familiar to you it's The Comedy Store in
Los Angeles where you performed many
times as a standup so I've done my bet
you did you did but actually this not
this is not the first time we meet in
person no no we did originally in London
last year and I know that many people
are watching this for the first time I
would know this but like I would really
love to tell the story of that moment
because uh I was having a a tour in the
UK and Europe and I was doing my English
standup and one of my uh you know
advertis promotion plan was to come on
your show so my Asian con is like B
you're going to be on Pierce Morgan I
said damn it's like what's wrong it's
like well uh Pierce Morgan blocked me on
Twitter and he said like what did you do
I said well during January 6th you know
Direction you know uh you tweeted
something about it and I was so angry at
what's happening and I remember you
having you and Donald Trump in a picture
and I said said the guy who had Donald
Trump with him whatever and then I I I
used like very harsh words and of course
you block me so I and then I said like
does he know I don't know does he know I
don't know does he know I don't know so
I walked into the studio and the moment
I was like being seated and there
preparing before we go on air and you
said oh hi Basim it seems that you have
more followers than me but it seems that
I blocked you
why and I told you and then we we said
the story on air and it was funny
because I made the J us like you have
always been standing against canceled
culture and you just canceled me theer
but we agreed that this is not canceling
because this is your own space and
you're free but now you're unblocked me
and we are and we're here we're here and
it was yeah and actually we agreed about
January the 6th by the way just for the
record um the I was done about you maybe
you weren't surprised I was completely
staggered by the response globally to
our interview several weeks ago were you
taken back by the scale of it uh yes of
course but I understand why um for many
years the media covering the Middle East
has uh been um showing a certain point
of view I'm not going to say bias but I
would say it did not allow certain
voices certain um voices from the other
side to be heard and that is why see the
frustration you all whenever you speak
to people in the Middle East they tell
you the same thing uh they they they not
very happy with the the coverage from
because our voices are not heard now I
am the least qualified person ever to
talk about this conflict and yet just
because I relate some of the talking
points that we say and we hear the whole
time people felt hurt and when you when
people have this feeling they they're
happy they are they have this response
they like oh my God for the for the
first time the West are actually hearing
our point of view some of the point of
view might not be go well with other
people but at least we have a
conversation and I think that is the
reason why people reacted that way yeah
it's it's such an incend subject matter
I've never seen social media so Ablaze
with hostility on on both sides did you
actually as well as enormous praise from
the Arab world did you also get
criticized by some parts of the Arab
world for not going perhaps hard enough
oh you didn't do that you didn't do that
thing is this is like uh your damn if
you do you them if you not right if you
don't speak up why don't you speak up if
you speak up you didn't speak up if
you're done why are you if you speak up
too much oh you're taking all the
attention on you and I I love that fact
because people always who accuse people
of being the center of attention they
are actually not very happy that the
attention is not from them this is
actually like a rule on social media but
yeah there was a backlash but there's
also a backlash from the other side
which um I I mean here and other comedy
clubs I worked with people from all kind
of different backgrounds Jewish
Christians Muslims Arabs atheists all
kinds of people and there are a lot of
people who went to to my social like oh
s a terrorist sympathizer now you know
and uh I think it is important to have
uh a
nuanced deep interesting intelligent
conversation a lot of people waiting for
this are kind yeah B very Pierce show
him and this is the problem with the
news today the problem the news today
it's not about the news anymore it's
about the people giving you the news so
it becomes a show a circus two
Gladiators in the
Coliseum two pigs fighting the mud and
this is why people don't get anything
out of it it's a circus you know one of
the things I heard a lot was who is this
guy and they weren't talking about me
sometimes sometimes I wonder
obviously you're very very well known in
the Arab world you're known as the kind
of they called you the Arab John Stewart
and you're well known in America but you
weren't that well known for example in
the UK uh and I think what this
interview did it made a lot of people
think wow all right this this is
incredible but tell me more about basam
MF and I I did a bit of research into
your life and is a fascinating Journey
that you've gone on to get here to Los
Angeles and I think it's worth just
taking a little beat here to talk about
this because you began in Cairo as a
heart surgeon I me that was your career
path yes and and you were a heart
surgeon I was a heart surgeon until yeah
uh I spent 19 years in that car 7 years
in medical school 12 years as a
practicing doctor and uh 2011 happened
and the revolution happened and I had my
own show on YouTube I did like small
videos well I'm going to come to this
because I was in I by coincidence I just
joined CNN to replace the great Larry
King and I hadn't actually done any live
show I'd done a few weeks since I joined
of taped interviews with big names
Donald Trump Oprah Winfrey things like
that and I was flying back to Los
Angeles when I got a message that Egypt
was going up in start of the Arab Spring
and I actually went to a studio very
near here about a mile down the road on
Sunset the CNN studio the old Larry King
studio and I went live for the first
time and it was about the Arab Spring it
was about what was happening in Egypt
and at the same time you in Egypt were
actually in teror square helping wounded
protesters actually medically treating
them yeah yeah uh I mean this was a kind
of movement that inspired a lot of
Egyptians um at the time I was you know
I was in the hospital and a lot of
people just volunteered and the nurses
was just like giving us like supplies go
go go and we were going there and we
were basically tending to the wounded
because it is and and it kind of gives
you a different perspective when you see
helpless defenseless people who do who
are not armed who are being beaten by
Security Forces military forces being
shot being uh you know hurt and uh all
we can do is just like provide some
medical attention and it kind of gives
you a perspective to see how Humanity
sometimes can show its most ugly faed
and the suppression of free speech
freedom of expression yeah the ability
of people to say what they honestly feel
about a situation and the suppression of
people's basic rights to Freedom
absolutely yeah and uh that kind of like
taught me a lot and uh and ins smir me
to do the show but you know well you
start it's a crazy story this and I I
want to tell it because you just decide
to do five minute stuff on YouTube yeah
and you are expecting a few people to
watch it and then literally it just
flies and suddenly you're getting
millions of people what watching this
and very quickly one of the big networks
comes in and then you're suddenly doing
this stuff for 30 to 40 million people
like a third of the entire population of
Egypt is tuning in to watch it you're
the biggest star of Egyptian television
oh please you are don't
stop sobody I mean what an extraordinary
thing though for a heart surgeon yeah to
go from helping protesters medically
into Ria Square the start of the Arab
Spring to within a year you're the
biggest star on Egyptian television it's
a crazy thing it it doesn't sound as
glamorous as this it's it feels it it
felt horrible did it why oh yeah
overnight Fame this size it's toxic
terrible terrible it it it's it corrupts
it it it it goes into your soul and it's
not good it's not I I I actually didn't
enjoy it uh and the worst the worst part
about is that like you're trying to do
comedy in very controversial Climate
about very controversial issues so
you'll never never satisfied people and
the problem is that you're people have
these expectations oh if you are
successful in this you must be
successful at solving this and when
things are not solved because Politics
as you
know very difficult to solve uh the the
that expectation this love turns into
hate and and and this is and this is one
of many many reasons that I had to leave
and I and I came here eventually well
let's just take people through what
happened because they probably don't
know a lot of people so during the
presidency of Muhammad
who was a democratically elected
islamist you you had relative freedom to
start but then the more you went after
government propaganda the more you stood
up for the people against the government
then the trouble started Mory wanted to
shut you up you eventually get dragged
through the courts I was arrested I was
arrested for one day it was a warrant
for my arrest and then I turned myself
in and I was interrogated and it was the
funniest interrogation ever and in my
stand-up shows I I I talk about that
scene cuz the guards were reading the
stuff out and laughing right well the
guards were taking selfies with me which
is funny and and the uh and and it the
exchange between me and the inter and
persecutor general persecutor was
extremely funny I mean I don't like to
victimize myself I just like oh look at
I actually like to find humor but why
were you arrested what was the criteria
oh yeah the I I think the list was
insulting Islam insulting the president
spreading false rumors and disrupting
the fabric of society
and uh and it was I think the people in
the room didn't know what to do with me
because they ended up discussing my
jokes so it turned into a writer's room
and I I was kind of like how do you
think we make this funnier and it was
the funniest exchange ever and after 6
hours I I was let go and uh was it scary
though at the same time that suddenly
the Machinery was getting a grip of you
because it was to get a lot scarier but
was it in that moment when when you
first got arrested you thought I'm being
arrested for breaching my freedom of
speech
right for some reason I I I just like
went with the flow I went to the
interrogation wearing the big hat I went
to the show it was it was just I I just
wanted this to be a force because I I
just like you you're really coming after
the comedian and it it was it I I I just
tried to enjoy myself but deep inside I
was dying well you actually it it gets
serious enough where you may have died
because actually Mory gets of course
deposed in comes a general LCC in a coup
a military coup and he doesn't find
satar a laughing matter particularly
when the jokes are about him you get
blocked they literally block your show
from
airing I aired one episode and it's
interesting this is this is a very
interesting story because the first
episode that was aired after after the
removal in the Muslim Brotherhood
everybody was waiting to see what I will
say because by that time all of the
Islamic channels that were me like me
and me and Islamic CH like it's like
they had five channels and they were
like me and them going like that they
they had like five channels I have only
one hour a week and then they were
removed and then a lot of the other
desent voices were also being shut down
now I people are waiting what will
bessim say and on the day that the show
aired the next day I went I went out and
everybody's like good good at least
somebody is speaking it was a very
controversial episode nobody liked it
and yet everybody liked it because
people said like you're supporting the
coup no you're the Muslim Brotherhood
everybody accused me of something all I
did in that episode was just being a
mirror of what is happening in the
street and showing them how ridiculous
it is you didn't take your fixed
position well my position depending on
where what's your position what did you
intend your position my my position was
to show the Ridiculousness of
how the people now was like oh we got
rid of Islamic fascism but we are
heading towards another fascism H there
was and there was a song that I did that
was very controversial people it's very
funny the the pr Muslim Brotherhood
thought that this is a disrespect to the
people who died and on the other side
the people said that this is a
disrespect to the Army and when you
manage to offend everybody you know
you're right yes and then the people in
the midd is like oh you weren't you
weren't tough enough and I was told I
like why didn't you go after the the the
the the the ceiling of Freedom just went
down and I was just like it was very
diff it is very difficult to go
against an an authority that is very
that was very popular at the time and
especially a military Authority with a
lot lot of experience oh yeah of
weaponizing these situations yeah you
had death threats people would always
choose most of the time they always
choose the military form rather than the
religious form because they they kind of
like uh at this they are not infringing
on my personal freedom not yet but uh
you had threats on your life didn't you
oh all the time I don't talk about that
because like I have been having death
threats like did never stopped since
2011 never stopped have they continued
since our last interview oh yeah they
never stopped people threatening to kill
you all the
time why for what reason oh for just
saying something that they don't like oh
because you you are against Egypt you're
against Islam you're against our
president you're against God it it never
stop
it never stops it doesn't doesn't bother
you I mean if you die you die you know
if you die you die I mean since since
when whatever like no bodyguards
deflected a bullet you know maybe the
guy who with ronal dragan but I I I I I
I think it's like whatever even like at
a certain point I actually had like
private security and then I told him I
can't I I cannot live like that if if
that's my destiny if I die
I
[Applause]
[Music]
you end up with your lawyer said you got
to get out of here you got to get out of
Egypt it's getting too dangerous yeah
something bad's going to happen you're
going to get arrested again and probably
Su in jail or you're going to going to
try and kill you and you flee to Dubai
mhm and then you end up here in America
yes was that always the plan to
eventually come to America or was it
expediency because of what happened well
it's funny that you said that because I
visited the United States after the
first year of my show and uh um a doctor
that's there Egyptian doctor has been
there for for a while I said listen
bessim you you are very visible in the
media and I think you can use that to
apply for a green card as a special
talent and I did and I said like I I I
have like a huge show criteria because I
have the same is uh an alien of
exceptional ability is what they call
you charmingly yes we're very
exceptionally able aliens we are but we
are still aliens yeah yeah I know it
always makes me laugh you can come here
but you are an alien alien but you're
exceptional and uh I um I just applied
for it and I got it I got the time 100
that help both from my uh my application
and said ah maybe I'm not going to use
it and then when that happens oh the
green card came handy so a lot of people
think that I'm heing Asylum I'm not I
just it was just a strike of luck you
now do stand up and you done it for 5
years and fascinating that you do some
of it for an Arab audience have an whole
in Arabic and and an English speaking
version and they probably very different
right because different sensibilities
different humor different crowds
different expectation M yes well will
the Arab audience come to my show they
expect that it's going to be another
version of my show that I did in Egypt
and I said no it's a my personal story
even then this weekend right before I
met you because of our interview I sold
out Arizona really yes and I and I and I
stood and the first thing I said like
who here came because over the PS Morgan
show I was like like I was like boy
you're going to be disappointed because
this is not about that but isn't that
amazing I mean that shows the power of
that interview resident even in in
Arizona here yeah because I don't want I
don't want to be I don't want to succeed
just because of a trending moment of
time it is the sh same show that I've
been working and perfecting and like any
standup comedian in the United States
your dream is what is to sell you
special to platforms like NEX HBO and
you want to get there because for me
that was like a like a re like a rebirth
because I thought like everything was
lost I came here I had
nothing first three four years it was
ter the first two years I was doing
standup oh I bombed hard I bummed hard
and I I went home crying I said I'm not
going to make it and then suddenly I
have already a tour I mean even before
our show I already had a set tour and
now I'm having like this ability of like
talking to people with different
languages talking to all these different
language the show that I did in Arizona
had an incredible mix of Arabs and
Americans and they came here and they
completely and there a lot of them came
they were Palestinians and they came
with like the Palestinian flags and the
CA and they thought it's like guys it's
like the way laughter being good at your
job in is in in its way a a way of
resistance before we can I can I can I
show okay so this is a gift from me and
my wife this is uh olive oil from the
West Bank ah whenever you go to I go to
Jordan a lot but my wife also like ask
for the oil from the West Bank it's very
good it is the best oil ever and the
thing is olive trees they they know they
survive up to 600 years M and they are
passed from one generation to the other
and uh it is like a family heritage and
the way that you do it so this is zat
zat is basically Thyme and you add to it
Sesame and a bunch of herbs and the way
that you eat that you take like a piece
of bread we don't have to do it now
maybe at the end of the interview the
end and you basically you soak it a
little bit in the oil and then you take
the Z and I'll
demonstrate
here and then and then here
I love it well I love Arabic food so at
the end of the interview you living with
this o I will take that it's your well
thank you and it's very kind of your
wife thank you thank you very much for
me well I'm done tooted but it's
okay obviously you started the last
interview with I mean I would argue
savagely dark humor involving your wife
how you've been trying to kill her and
she was using your kids as human Shields
and stuff and I I'll be honest with you
I'm still trying to but I but you know
what when I failed you know what I did M
I went out to the house and I just like
randomly slapped other neighbors you
know it's interesting by mistake now
this time I'm ready for you okay this
time I'm ready for the humor oh you're
ready okay no but it's interesting
because last time I was very taken aback
and I remember thinking as you were
doing this at right off the top I
remember feeling very uncomfortable
unusually uncomfortable and thinking I
didn't know how to react to that I
didn't know whether I was supposed to
laugh or be silent or and I sort of
ended up sort of slightly grimacing half
laugh and listening and then I realized
it was very powerful what you were doing
it was satirical but it was savagely
satirical and extremely effective and
that's why I think the interview did so
well you know why because all I did was
just take the talking points that's been
in the media not just for after October
7th all through the conflict it's always
like we need to kill it all right you
need to kill five no kill 10 you need to
kill some no kill all this is what
satire does he takes it take take
reality flipped on his head exaggerate
and then you can see how sometimes very
uncomfortable and even sometimes stupid
that sounds
because I was just reacting to whatever
the media is telling me it's like oh
yeah okay good do it govern there's no
push back so suddenly the person who's
proposing The Most Extreme Measures like
oh take oh that's too much so that that
was like a very simple technique I just
talk took the talk point and just
exaggerated it was it was devastatingly
effective I think um first before we go
any further how is your wife's family
because she is a Palestinian yeah are
they okay are they they're good they're
good they are safe for now yeah um in as
like that last week there was no
internet as you have yes you know I saw
you tweet at the IDF it's like how can
they know you know how many views that
tweets at nearly 40 million yeah me just
saying how are they going to see this
message if you've cut the internet off
I'm I'm wondering if the IDF like why
aren't the Palestinians liking my tweet
because they don't see it right no but I
thought that was a perfectly correct
assessment of it yeah um but the
reaction to that tweet I did was
enormous as everything is in this in
this thing I had a lot of people say
finally appears you get it right finally
you get it and and I wanted to say
listen I'm I'm trying to reach a place
where I get this but it's an incredibly
complicated issue for someone who is not
Arabic or Jewish to poke their head into
and I've had to cover it as a journalist
for a long long time I think I said to
you before that I was elit of a Daily
Mirror in England when we opposed the
Iraq War for example so you know I have
taken stands on this thing on this one I
find and I'm going to be completely
straight with you I discussed this with
Jordan Peterson um this week and he did
a pretty incur tweet in which he said
give him hell Netanyahu enough is enough
and he was actually very self-reflective
about that in the interview we did this
week where he later issued issued a 20
minute video because he said sometimes a
a oneline tweet can be unnecessarily
inflammatory to people much better to
take time to explain it here's here's
where I've got to with this conflict
now I viewed what happened on October
the 7th as an absolutely appalling
atrocity a terror attack of unimaginable
horror and I absolutely think that
Israel has a right to defend itself from
the people who committed it and mass and
I've questioned for the last 3 4 weeks
what is a proportionate response and I
have said repeatedly I don't know the
answer I want people who have a view to
have a view about that and I'll ask you
again about where you think we are with
this I also acknowledge that Hamas live
among civilian population in Gaza and
therefore if you do what the Israelis
are currently doing which is a ground
offensive into Gaza a lot of civilians
are going to get killed and at what
point does that become dis
disproportionate or even
illegal and I don't know the answers to
those questions and I have a moral
quandry because my instinct is to say
that Israel has no choice but to respond
to what happened in a very forceful
manner I understand why they want to
eliminate Hamas Al together I understand
that if they feel they can then perhaps
we can move to a a two-state solution or
peace or whatever it may be although I
don't think that yahu will ever be the
person to do that but the the moral
question for me is at what point does
this become disproportionate and when
you see thousands of children being
killed in Gaza it fills me with utter
horror and then people say well do you
condemn it and I find it very easy to
condemn Israel turning off the water
Israel turning off the power I think
it's terrible what's happening in the
West Bank with the settlers I think that
the stuff there is completely easy to
condemn but can I hand on heart condemn
Israel trying to destroy Hamas after
what they did on October the 7th that is
where I'm struggling to find myself
saying I condemn it because I believe
that they are right to try and Destroy
Hamas now what do you feel about my
moral quandry well there is there's a
lot of points very lot and I think this
is this was kind of like uh Le the
ground rules for that uh interview there
is the whole thing about like
is right to defend itself the
condemnation first of all let's start
with condemnation yes you want my
opinion yes condemning Hamas or
condemning Israel yes completely useless
completely useless why you I condemn
Hamas you condemn Israel interview is
over what happened nothing it is just
checkpoint like morality checkpoints but
I've interviewed a lot of pro
Palestinians for example some of whom
will immediately say I unreservedly
condemn the terror attacks of October
the 7th and then go on to criticize is
and I think that's a very a position I
can completely respect but I find it
much harder to respect a pro Palestinian
guest on my show if they simply
resolutely refuse to say that they can
condemn the terror attacks I find that
less worthy of respect but you see this
is the problem with the news we go into
the circular motion of the same as one
thing that I have noticed not just on
the coverage of these events the the the
events before and 4 and four every time
this starts people say we don't know
what's happening it's a very complicated
situation what is happening now and for
me as a viewer if a conflict has been
there for 75 years and the media with
all this technology has been covering it
and we hear the same exact words we
don't know what's happening it's
complicated it's a very complex that is
a failure of the media apparatus that is
the failure to themselves and for the
audience because why every time this
happens it seems like it is happening
from from from from point zero and I
think to help understand that I will get
to October 7th I will get to the
condemnation I will get to the
selfdefense but I think maybe we can do
we we have like all the time in the
world and we can discuss this could this
interview could be a bookmark Landmark
for maybe looking at that conflict in a
deeper way that nobody had gone there
before we have the views we have people
waiting you know as a said I'm the least
qualified to discuss that but it's an
opportunity to use listen I'm not
massively well qualified myself yeah
both of us like an Irish Catholic I mean
look at us two privileged people one
white one one white white wannabe
discussing discussing the the most
complex conflict of of our of our
history
but
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan I'm sensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong yeah and your face just
starred out at me me and you conquer
time who wins you
do you know what I love about to today
we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
R I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose
L stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like High
consults don't really know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X form you known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tock then
yeah problem solved there you go who's
fit as a butcher dog him all right but
but he's now middle class us here Tess
but I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know now you're
probably going to boot me off show
this Kevin oiv is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass talking
for a
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King CBE
I think there's only room for one king
man you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
folk when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no know
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
had you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth this is to York
TV I've never met anyone like him and I
don't think I ever will again you only
consumated your relationship on your
wedding night that's right did you feel
Elvis was a controlling influence on you
controlling his death was something that
shook the entire world devastating my
big fear was Lisa she was only nine at
the time Lisa of course at one stage was
married briefly to Michael Jackson were
you concerned mhm very the Elvis movie
was being fated at the Golden Globes
within 48 hours and she incredibly sadly
died that hug was the last hug I gave
her I was just wondering actually
genuinely how you were doing it has been
pretty tough you know I lost my mom then
I lost my grandson then I lost my
daughter I don't know exactly how to
answer
that don't talk anymore
that can you stop the camera
please
[Music]
I want to start in a totally different
area I want to start with anti-Semitism
yes I think it's an important issue yes
I think there is a rise of anti-em
semitism in the world and I think there
is uh this is very dangerous and I as a
Muslim who has been through events where
there were terrorist attacks somewhere
and that reflects to us on us I I
completely completely feel that uh and I
think it is very
important to agree on the language
because the word
anti-semite has been used and abused and
most most of the time not on for the you
know for the good in um interest of the
Jewish people because the first two days
of the coverage I watched the news and I
and there was a lot of um protest that
was led by Jewish voice for peace and
they were read by people who opposed the
Israeli attack on the civilians and I
remember quite well many of the
Republican representatives in Congress
came out and they were calling these the
global intifada the global Jihad I love
it when they say Jihad they sound like a
horse Jihad it's very funny and or they
they say like these are and I quote
Iranian backed jihadists and I said wait
a minute but most of those people are
Jewish those people who took over the
capital the same people who took over
Central Station in New York which is
known as the biggest Civil Disobedience
event in America in the last two decades
they were all Jewish and then I find
Niki Haley saying anti-zionism equals
anti-Semitism and then I find Nikki haly
saying anti-zionism equals anti-semitism
and then I remember it's like oh Jewish
people in America are saddled by the
fact that they are not citizens of
America or citizens of the world but
they are citizens of Israel and they
have to back Israel in whatever they do
and these are not my words these are the
words of John Stewart he went out and he
said I said like and he said it's is
very very important to divide these two
and what is very very interesting would
you compare that on that specific point
to the way that people try and say all
Palestinians are responsible and
accountable for what Hamas do yes in
other words I think you can be very
critical of Israeli government and their
policies and Benjamin Netanyahu and the
politicians but that doesn't mean that
you have to take that criticism to
innocent Israelis who may have exactly
the same criticism themselves and this
is why it is very important to have
these kind of discussions because it the
funnest not the funniest the saddest
thing that I saw is the people that were
in so so much support of Israel are
anti-semite themselves MTG MTG MTG uh
Mer Taylor green you know she said like
oh those are I send my AIDS and they
took pictures of the protesters
basically she's surveilling protesters
and Mery Taylor green is very known for
a very famous Post in 2018 where she
blamed the California wildfire fires on
a Jewish space laser gun
do you remember that do you remember
that I just like oh they were bur
because Jewish investors Rothchild and
finin anything with that ends with Stein
because that's of course sounds of
Jewish they put a satellite and shooting
laser beams
to and and and not just her you have
Steve skolis SK thank you so much he is
the now the the speaker of the house and
he has been invited before in a in a for
an organization that was funded by David
Duke the founder of the KKK you have
Kevin McCarthy who is the former
minority speaker leader of of Republican
party in the house and he accused Jewish
billionaires of rigging the midterm so
how come those people are accusing us of
anti-semite so here's the thing so go
let's go to the equation that Niki Haley
put on Twitter anti-zionism equals
anti-Semitism no it is true people who
hate Jews they also anti it is true and
you could be someone who hate Zionist
who don't like Zionist and you are
Semite you could even be Jewish and
guess what you could be a Zionist like
those
people uh supporting Israel and at the
same time you hate the Jews because the
chat Jews will not replace us these
echoed in Charlottesville it did not
echo in Gaza I mean in Gaza they say War
stuff in in between the bombing under
down time but and these are the same
people who are seen with Nick
Fuentes with uh with
with Steven B and you know what's had
him for dinner Mar and all of those
people are buddies with Benjamin
Netanyahu so how does this work how does
this work and you know the people who
speak against this like John Stewart
Like Bernie Sanders like uh Naomi Klein
what do they call these people what do
they call them
self-hating Jews and know what else now
now they call them they call them capus
capus you know what's capus capus
basically these were the Jewish inmate
in osit that were forced by the Nazis to
stand as guards on their own inmates you
see how degrading this is and this is
the way to shut down conversation
anti-semite islamophobe you hate America
you hate the military you hate Egypt war
on Christmas this is how you should an
environment that does not allow
disagreement is not an environment made
for it's an envirment for control let me
ask you this on say the student protests
in America universities I have no
problem instinctively with students
protesting is actually part of the DNA
of being a student right but I do have a
problem with two things one the protest
that happened almost immediately after
October the 7th within hours which were
clearly deeply deliberately inflamatory
and hurtful to Jewish
people secondly I have a real problem
with the students who were beaming
direct pramas slogans onto buildings on
campuses in America you know I'm for
free speech and I really am the whole
show is predicated from that but not to
the point where you see Jewish students
barricaded into libraries because a mob
is descending on them there is a
distinction to me between people who are
obviously overtly I mean there was a
professor at Cornell University who was
literally seen in public shouting how
exhilarated he felt by the attacks of
October the 7th he still hasn't been
fired that guy I think that crosses a
line do you yeah I do not like this way
I mean I can understand why but I don't
condone it I would never because you
have to understand these people again
I'm not supporting them I just want to
make sure about two things the reason
that I started with anti-Semitism
because I wanted to make sure to clear
any confusion that when I speak about
Israel I'm speaking about Israel yes
when I speaking about Jewish people I'm
speaking about Jewish people yes when I
speaking speak it's very because no I
think it was very powerful that he did
that yeah I have that's the first thing
you did because I think it's really
important yeah but at the same time when
I tell you why does that happen it
doesn't mean that I condone it there's a
difference between explanation and
justification those people who are
exhilarated the way that they this is
the the same uh reason why people were
so happy about the interview what do
they see they see Israel as a criminal
State who is killing their people and in
the same time they are supported by the
International Community America they
have no guns they have no superpower
backing them all they have is just
feeling of Happiness like yes our
enemies that we cannot touch them has
been hurt all they can think about that
these are their enemies that have been
hurt right I'm not condoning this but
again like when people were uh
celebrating terrorist attacks you know
against Western uh Western targets of
course I don't condone that but why
because those people has been from from
a very young age what have they seen
they're not being heard by the media the
The Plight and the suffering of their
Brothers in is in in Palestine in the
Arab world are not being here people in
Iraq you know like when when America and
Britain invaded Iraq right what what the
Arabs so it's like two superpowers are
coming in on on just regular people so
whenever there was like a bomb or like
an attack on American troops people
would celebrate yeah they our enemies
emotions are very inflammatory and it is
not right but those people had nothing
else all they just like shout all they
say is like to to to to rejoice it is
not right again I'm explaining why is
this happening because it's like yeah if
I cannot get you I'm just going to
scratch your eyes I'm going to scratch
your eyes because because you've been
beating me all the time and you have the
whole International Community backing
you up and all I can do is Scream is it
right no but it is understandable again
not the right thing but I it's not like
understandable it's like oh I no but
again it is an
explanation
[Music]
[Applause]
what does the Western audience see they
see people rejoicing for the death of
innocent civilians in
Israel this is what have the Arabs seen
for years in in on the Arab board for
example if you look up sidro
cinema this is in 2014 when when Israel
was bombing Gaza as usual and the
Israelis in the sidro uh uh Kuts or the
the settlement they were s they went on
a hill and they had popcorn and they had
drinks and they were like watching the
show and they were cheering with every
rocket coming down this is what we see
Western people didn't see that well
somebody found a tweet actually of mine
from 2014 in which I said at what point
does what Israel is currently doing to
the Palestinian people become terrorism
and because I've always said you know
I've spoken about this a lot over the
years and I've always try to be
extremely fair-minded orbe it nobody
really wants you to be fair- minded they
want you to take a side but that was
clear that my thinking back then was
that they were absolutely overstepping
absolutely absolutely but I'm again to
the point of rejoicing no I know what
you mean but like if you for example
Google Google the wedding of hate this
is like a Jewish wedding in Israel where
they were celeb ating the ARs and
Palestinian to be clear I've seen lots
of video but I'm not talking to you
pierce I'm talking to the Western
audience because because I want to see
like I want to say like this is what
they see I mean for example there is a
very famous video for Sam abuan who is
like a young kid that he was shot Point
Black by an Israeli soldier and he was
not allowed to have any medical
attention and as his dead body was being
put into the Abul ambulance the Jewish
settlers were cheering so for an Arab
audience this is what we see every day
so when they see oh we heard them back
we heard their people like their heard
back it is not right but this is what
hates does it escalates it feeds each
other radicalism feeds it it is terrible
and it is a it is just like a vicious
circle so I would like to do something
that is very interesting tonight I want
when I invited John Stewart to my show
as much of like a reception that you if
if you see on the YouTube people just
like we had to cut the 5 minute standing
ovation for broadcast people was on
their feet for 5 minutes they could not
believe it I remember John telling me I
could never imagine that a Jewish guy
from New Jersey would have that kind of
reception in K and yet on the internet
people who would what you brought a Jew
on your show why you are with a Jew yes
hate is there and I want to do something
very interesting today I want to give I
I I'm I'm I like telling stories and I'm
going to tell you a very nice story this
is the story surprise surprise of the
suffering and the plight of the Jewish
people and I want to say that because it
is very inter when you see the
trauma and the suffering that the people
on the other side went through you might
understand why why they coming so so
this
is see this mhm this is a map of all of
the history of the expulsion of the Jews
in Europe they've been like I have not
never seen a minority being kicked
around this much right and of course
this comes back to the you know the
whole idea about the original sin that
you have uh betrayed the uh Jesus Christ
the the the the the the blood of Jesus
is on your head and then comes the 11th
century at that time Jewish people were
not allowed to own land they were just
peasants even some of the professions
are not even allowed to participate in
but they were allowed to do one thing
usually money lending because it was
prohibited by the Catholic Church to
engage into that so what happens when
you work in money you get richer right
and those Jews lefted in ghettos now
ghettos was not just like isolated
neighborhoods in cities sometimes
ghettos were outside the city this is
like how isolated they were and in those
GTO they have to pay gold to the mayor
or the governor or the prince or the
noble
so they would see you're getting richer
I need more taxes so they pay tax what
happens when you have a business and
they increase your rent you increase
your service increase the tax so what
happened what the Christians started to
default and suddenly the image of the
greedy Jew was created Merchant
of Venice this was the kind of
Oppression that the Jewish people went
through fast forward 19th century there
was like the Eastern Jew in Ukraine and
and Russia and there was the Western
Jews in
Europe those people in the East the easn
Jews had to immigrate because they were
pgms and they were like you know kicked
out and that and a certain point the
people in the west especially in England
it's like there are too many Jews we
need a solution a solution for what for
the Jewish problem so it's like we need
to get rid of them and you know what
Palestine was not even on the in the a
list Palestine was in the b list because
England proposed 6,000 square miles in
Uganda for the Jews 1903
and the reason why Palestine was not on
the list that it was objected by a lot
of rabbis that said like it's a Promised
Land but only when the Messiah comes but
there were other options Argentina South
Africa Uganda Madagascar and eventually
they said all right let's do Palestine
so they went to Palestine
1914 there was 700,000 people living in
Palestine 3% were Jewish 1917 Bel for
declaration Arthur Belfor he called the
Jewish people in England that they are
alien and hos child race and the thing
is the only Jewish member of the
parliament of the English Parliament
Lord mono he objects like these are
British citizens they we should not kick
them out so they pushed them they pushed
them but it was not going fast enough
came the Nazis and then it was not about
the solution anymore it was the end
losing the Final Solution by Hitler
because he needed an answer for the
Jewish question the
you and then the as you see the
Holocaust happened the most orchestrated
in mized horrible genocide in our modern
time 6 million Jews di so it accelerated
and they went the first of all they left
Eastern Europe and they went to West
Europe and went to America and they were
turned down and they were pushed towards
Palestine so by 1948 right before the
Declaration of the state of Israel there
were 2 million people living there only
30% of them was Jews so the whole idea
of like a land without a people to a
people without a land it was a marketing
thing they were already Palestinians so
suddenly overnight 1948 there were one
1.5 million Palestinians seven half of
them three4 of them were overnight
pushed into refugees and this is why
it's called the neba the catastrophe so
now we have all of this building up into
the minds and that and suddenly this was
like a conflict a hate a problem that we
didn't have to do anything with this was
basically pushed on us by the Europeans
you see so this is why it is important
to say that and I'm not saying that just
like oh let's Wipe Out the state of
Israel let's like push up in the sea no
but it's important when you talk about
the conflict that you talk about the
root causes right no there were there
was like a vibrant Palestinian culture
happening over there and right now they
are erasing this culture suddenly I'm
seeing of like Israeli feta cheese
Israeli homus oh that's an insult
Israeli homus come on I mean take the
land but leave the homos man I mean come
on I mean that's that's not fair you are
someone who's always spoken against
culture cancel culture right now a whole
culture is cancel
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just St
out me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about tour today
we do it all sunak sella
gon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of Booz up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose I am
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
less spotted new the problem lies in the
bureaucrat it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X form you known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then yeah problem problem solved
there you go who's fit as a Butch's dog
him all right but but he's now middle
class us here Tess I nearly have empathy
when I'm speaking to them I know no
you're probably going to Boop me after
show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we hav
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King
Cube I think it's only room for one king
man you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
folk when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
had you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
marish Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
question
thank God for talk TV is not only the
home of common sense it's the only place
where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV let let me ask you this Jonathan
Friedland is a top Jewish journalist for
the Guardian newspaper Pap he wrote a
very interesting column last week in
which he
said at the root of all this you could
argue you have two sets of people with
just
calls and they believe passionately in
their Just
Cause And he was sort of advising people
not to take sides unless you really
understand the history do you would you
agree with that would you agree that
both sides have legitimate just cause
not with the methodology that's taken
place and you've given an extremely
detailed analysis of the buildup to what
happened in 48 to me it's pretty clear
700 800,000 Palestinians were displaced
from their homes and it should never
have happened and that has been
absolutely I think the root cause for so
much resentment but can you at the heart
of this debate agree with Jonathan that
you could argue there's just cause on
both sides there there's a cause on both
sides but I I I'm I'm working on a tight
robe here because not a
Palestinian uh but from the Palestinian
point of view there's a lot of people I
mean there are 2.2 million people living
in Gaza there are 3.5 million people
living in the West Bank there is 350,000
people lifting East and there's like six
or seven million people living outside
those people the Palestinian that were
pushed out they do not have the right to
go back right now if you meet
Palestinians you'll see them wearing a
necklace with a key that key is their
house that they were kicked out from in
yafa and he you know like my my my
wife's family comes from ramla which is
50 mil from Gaza and and and according
to the law those people have absolutely
no right to go back even you if you are
a Palestinian with an American passport
they give you hell in order to go in and
yet a Jewish person born anywhere in the
world born in Poland born in the Ukraine
no question ask he can jump on a plane
land in Israel and get the the the the
Israeli citizen and take a house that
most probably belonged to a Palestinian
so it is not just like it is an ongoing
Injustice that has been happening now I
mean where would you criticize if you're
being fairm minded where would you
criticize from 48 onwards the behavior
of the Arab side well put yourself in
the Arab side at 1948 you constituted
70% of the population suddenly the UN is
giving you 48% of the land
right not just that I mean the Arab
regimes because they did terribly and
see this is the thing Arab nationalism
at the height of these people feed on
each other you know because it's very
very important to have a problem oh it's
Israel and then and for is oh it's the
Palestinian it's a very good distraction
I mean sometimes I feel that like the
Palestinian cause is very useful for
both sides to stay there as attention
because it's always a way to reflect but
uh and this is a very important question
because the in the mind of the western
audience they always thought of the
Palestinian resistance or the
Palestinian side as like Islamic as
militant no as a matter of fact some of
the early suicide bombers were female
Christian Palestinians because they like
the r you know they were fighting for a
land the whole idea of islamization of
the whole cause came very later as a
matter of fact you will find this very
interesting because when I saw this I
did not believe it this you know the fat
movement which is the PLO the fat this
was their uh
slogan can you see you see there's a
crescent a cross and a minora and they
say unitary Democratic non sectarian so
basically in the 1960 fat were basically
marijuana smoking Tre hugger hippies and
yet that didn't work right and the thing
is I always hear that like Arabs were
were giving two four so many chances for
peace that is not true as a matter of
fact all along history Israel didn't
give an inch of land by peace 1974 73
War they gave back Sinai because Egypt
like initiated the war 2006 they went
out of uh south of Lebanon because of
the resistance they have even the
disengagement of of Gaza they didn't do
it out of the goodness of their heart
because they had too much casualties and
even even even the oso Accords the peace
treaty the one that Isaac raban and got
the Nobel priz they did it because of
the antifa so what is the message that
Israel is giving to the Arabs I will
never give you anything with peaceful
resolution you will always have to fight
for it you not think that for example I
mean Bill Clinton feels this very
strongly that there was a great deal to
be done and Arafat just in the end
having indicated the whole time that if
we got to this place there would be a
deal just walked away that that was the
closest that everybody came and but
actually I mean could Clinton have done
any more than he tried to do then I am
not again that's why it's very important
to have people who are much more
qualified than me to talk about this but
two things I can say about that number
one
uh the the whole thing about the OA
Accord there was a video for Netanyahu
who was talking to the S offer 2001 and
he was bragging about
sabotaging the he was talking to like I
sabotage it like there was going to be
no peace yeah you've seen that right and
in that video if you remember when when
he was saying like you have to hit them
hard 2001 no Hamas at the time we have
they were talking about the Palestinian
Authority we have to hit them we have to
kill them we have to make them feel the
pain and then one of them say like like
BB but wouldn't America kind of je like
so what the American public is easily
manipulated 80% are with us it is absurd
and as a new American where I can have
the um privilege of being
retrospectively angry I said like this
guy is mocking the government who is and
the people who have been with him all
the time it's like oh they can be easily
manipulated they can do and even by the
way even Isaac Robin Isaac Robin the the
one who actually did the peace out he
was known famously so the way to
actually beat those children is to break
their bones called the broken bones
policy they would like get those kids
and break their bones on the FV so this
has the whole idea about like Israel
wanted peace and Arabs only wanted to
fight is a very very bad representation
think as it's gone on the will the
genuine will on both sides for peace has
not existed no I think it's been a
deceit to the world I'm and and to the
relative groups of people on both sides
the official and actually a betrayal of
the official stand of the Palestinian
Authority and again I cannot speak it is
very difficult to do this the official
send of the Palestinian Authority is
that we we are just happy with 22% of
the land just give us like the yes there
are people that this but the thing is
you cannot just say okay let's talk
about peace and then you take away my
land let's talk about peace and there's
there's a kind of like passive
aggressiveness happening oh let's talk
about but I'm going to build settins I'm
going to suffocate your cities and your
Villages see I think that has been
incredibly inflammatory yes worsening
the situation I think putting back the
chance of peace I mean Netanyahu I
interviewed Netanyahu earlier this year
in the middle of a big social protests
in his own country and I couldn't
understand what he thought he was doing
except that it seemed to me political
expediency that he had to to get power
uh you know again he had put a bunch of
right-wing Headbangers into his cabinet
who have incredibly bad records speak in
an incredibly incend way about uh
Palestinians for example and he did this
for power and then he launched a because
they were pushing in him to do it a
ridiculous assault on the Integrity of
the Supreme Court the independ of
Supreme Court and and many Israelis rose
up so Netanyahu is has become to me a
big problem right and and the people
that all the polling shows that Israeli
people are very unhappy with Netanyahu I
don't think he's ever going to actually
want to forge peace and in fact I think
he was instrumental with Hamas in
wanting to keep them in power because he
felt that that would create the split
with the Palestinian two political
groups and that would be good for Israel
and it was leaked in a leak Hood uh
conference in 2019 that he was bragging
about giving Hamas money because this is
a way that we can keep Palestinian
divided and yet so we and we'll never
have so this is a guy who was look we
can agree about Netanyahu I think no but
not just Netanyahu there there's a book
I say most of his cabin there's a book
called the fear of Peace it's by mush
Zimmerman and he's an Israeli historian
and he said like the average Israeli
citz does not have a vision of Peace
because for 70 years this is a country
that has been the military war has been
going on for they have been expanding
because of war the milit is taking over
so the whole idea of peace is not even
there it's not just Netanyahu like like
you have I remember you have interviewed
Neftali Benet yes and I think you
tweeted that like that was like a very
um kind of reasonable take I don't think
I said reasonable yeah yeah but like I
this
NE in he went after Queen R and he call
a shame on Queen R I didn't say
reasonable I just said this I did a fire
Emoji yeah yeah I just said that what he
was saying yeah I mean I was going to
ask you about Queen Ryan let's ask about
since you've raised it because Queen Ria
accused the west of a glaring double
standard she said this the first time in
modern history there's such human
suffering and the world is not even
calling for ceasefire so the silence is
deafening and to many in our region it
makes the Western World complicit
uh now other people said well okay if
you feel that
strongly why aren't you taking in any
Palestinians why is Egypt not taking
Palestinians why does the Arab world
want to constantly attack Israel without
actually offering any place to go for
the Palestinians and what do you say to
that that is exactly what Israel wants
and that is exactly what actually starts
third War I this is the war ution these
are palestin these are their lands and
then sudden they take them why so they
being basically kicked around from their
homes and now another country should
take them you see what would happen
imagine this now and because Israel
official has been talking openly about
this it's like why don't they just go in
sin why they go you know what would
happen those people going to be pushed
in Sinai and with any population 2
million people that are living in
refugee camp what do you think will
happen unrest uh chaos and then after a
few years the Western media will come
with their cameras like oh look at those
Arabs oh they're killing each other oh
Israel is good that they got rid of them
and then they will go to the West Bank
and soly those 3.5 million people
pushing into Jordan This the whole idea
why does Jordan take them why does Egypt
take them the same
question Europe has 44 countries why
don't they take
Israel America has 50 states why don't
they give them Florida I mean they we
seem to complain about Florida the whole
time why don't they just like give
Israel the whole idea was like oh you're
Arabs you're all the same no no no
because what will happen that so Israel
will move into Jordan it's like oh Saudi
why don't you take the
Jordanian this is not a solution this is
not a solution I I hear I'm not taking a
position out the way let me ask you
direct I want to say something about
what queen rer said okay the whole idea
about like the West yeah I think that in
3 weeks Israel morally corrupted the
West like no other I think the West will
have a lot of time to recover because
for years the West has been telling us
oh look we are liberal we're all about
human rights all are equal adopt our
values and then suddenly but you you
don't want to even to cease you don't
want to even tell Israel to stop and
suddenly we woke up and found McDonald's
are giving free meals to the Israeli
because like nothing will make you feel
better after killing a bunch of
Palestinian kids than a Happy Meal you
know
[Applause]
[Music]
what Israel will say because they say it
to me every time they come on the
program whoever from meu Barak to
Natalia Bennett whoever it may be they
say look we suffered such a catastrophic
terror attack on October the 7th that we
have decided we are going to get rid of
Hamas there are 40,000 or so Hamas
terrorists in their eyes who need to be
got rid of and I do believe they're
terrorists only terrorists can commit
the kind of Act of terrorism we saw so
can we on that point can we agree on
that do you believe Hamas is a terror
group it is what it is classified by
America I I'm not a big fan of Hamas and
they are militant group they does like
stuff like are they terrorist do you
think yeah cool okay okay so we agree on
this so you have 40,000 of them live
living in Gaza amongst the civilian
population if Israel has decided to
eliminate a terror group Hamas as the
world did with Isis for example and I
think there are a lot of parallels given
the way they behave in October 7th to
Isis how do you do it how do you do it
if you don't do it the way Israel is
currently trying to do it exactly not
the way that Israel does it because if
you have the one of the most advanced
military powers in the world and it
takes you 3 weeks 9,000 Palestinian
civilian death 21,000 injured as we are
talking right now Israel just bombed
Galia which is a known refugee camp this
it is a very this is a this is not
self-defense you know like one of the
most questions like does Israel have the
right to defend itself this is a nov
value question this is a no value
question well I would ask a different
point I would say not only do they have
a right to defend themselves which every
country would after a terror attack
right but they actually have a duty and
responsibility to their population to
try and stop that happening again to
them they've been doing and I do I do
understand and I agree with that yeah
but but here's the thing if it takes you
all of that time all of these civilians
to take out a few hundred gorilla
Fighters we don't know how many of the
people di we don't know it doesn't
matter but you don't know and I don't
know we don't know but like we don't
even know if casualty numbers are
correct because they're all coming from
Hamas and we the health auth and we
should believe Israel no no not
necessarily no no I I don't believe
either side but but but here's my
problem with this but here's my point I
don't think we should assume that we
know these statistics are correct I
don't think we should assume we know
exactly how many children have been
killed we do know a lot have been killed
so the moral argument Remains the Same
but we don't know how many Hamas
terrorists have been killed in the last
few weeks we just don't know do we so
basically we're we're dealing with a
very incompetent military force that has
been sucking America dry for years and
then they cannot do the job but how else
do they get rid of himass not like that
how do they do it I don't know but not
like that because they've been trying
you have another they have first of all
I'm not a military expert second of all
second of all they've been trying the
same thing for years they go in
they this is not an eye for an eye
anymore this is an eye a limp a life a
house a neighborhood a whole population
for an eye they don't see I mean your
your friend Ben shapira that you
particularly despise oh I love bapir
he's very smart yeah but you you've been
very critical of him and that's fair
enough I'm sure he would be of you but
when I asked him about proportion he
said there is I don't care about a
proportionate response so let's K
civilians as Hamas did this so we are
going to get rid of Hamas it's it's not
in his eyes it wasn't I for an i tooth
for a tooth it was this group of
terrorists did this and we are now going
to rid the world of these terrorists and
this is very important to look at things
in context when you see how Israelis
Talk inside their Community there was a
very famous post by or edit he is the uh
Speech writer of Nan he said what is so
horrific about understanding that the
whole Palestinians people are our
enemies all of them are enemy compa we
should call them kill their mother
destroy their homes the homes that they
raise those snakes so no snakes would be
raised in this house anymore and this
was reposted by Al Chet which is the
Minister of wait for it
justice those this it's not about Hamas
anymore it is not about H they can tell
you it's about Hamas but it's not about
it is basically it has they have said it
many times Pierce this is a way to kind
of push them into Sinai this is not
about eradicating Hamas this ship has
sailed I am sorry but like I anybody who
still believe that this is about Hamas
is stupid because they I don't agree
with that really no because I think but
why so why are why there I tell you I
don't agree there like 100 people any
country any country that suffered the
kind of terror attack that Israel
suffered with the kind of death toll
that occurred that day 1500 plus people
grandmothers kids young women being
raped kidnapped beheaded it's been
reported and so on well you can raise an
eyebrow I mean they found they found a
young woman's skull right somehow Som
been what about the babies that were
beheaded well there was a report and you
and I have this discussion on there you
falsely quoted me and I wanted to
clarify that with you in person you
thought I'd said that 40 babies had been
beheaded I never I said that did you I
said it's been reported that 40 babies
were killed some of whom had been
beheaded that's what I said yeah totally
totally different it's a very different
well it is different yes you accept it
um English is a second language so
they're different things of course yes
between saying 40 babies have been
beheaded and 40 babies have been
reported to been killed including some
are those beheaded well apparently
journalists have being shown utterly
horrific okay this is this comes to a
very important question
about credibility again I'm not
condoning what happened o but in I'm not
a journalist but as a journalist
wouldn't you take anything that an
authority would say with a grain of
thought yes especially if this Authority
have a
long history of lying and I'm just going
to give a few example 1996 they bombed
Kan it's a refugee camp they killed 106
people despite the they knew it's a
refuge Camp they said oh maybe it's a
one time off 2006 they W con again 2014
they killed two teenagers at checkpoint
they denied as usual but CNN was there
so they said we have to say it 2018 they
killed a medic a Palestinian medic and
they doctored they fabricated a video
showing that it's someone else that he
was a human shield and then can I just
like finish want respond and and then
2010 they killed Ahmed orat denied it
then said it's okay it's us 20121 they
bombed the media office in it's not us
but no I'm sorry and then 11th May 20 22
Shireen reporter your colleague she's
Palestinian American citizen she was
shot in the head and they provided
forensic evidence and even a doctor
video that it was not them it was
Islamic Jihad how can I expect to
believe this regime especially if the
president of Israel comes down with this
ridiculous ridiculous thing have you
seen in there there he said okay this
was reported by Sky News and it was the
funniest thing I've SE so this was a
call and po moment but like the cheap
Edition Mr uh hok said like Isaac hok
it's like we have
found evidence on one of the uh um
terrorist a manual to create chemical
bombs and then he showed this and he
showed and this is I just want to say
why would a foot shoulder go in into
enemy with like a manual to chemical
bombing it's like is that Bob bring own
beer bomb it's it's crazy and and what
what you like have like local
ingredients to make and then this it's
like this is a manual of of course conv
and let me read to you in Arabic because
this is
funny which basically
say this is basically like a catalog for
self-improvement for
M I didn't know that they have life
coaches so this and you know what sky
new said is like we cannot confirm or
any of this but we will show it
anyways this is like this is a lying
government so let me respond I do think
the Israeli government has lied all the
time right I do think they've lied I'm
not going to dispute that I do think
they've been caught lying I do think
they said things that turned out not to
be true I also think that two weeks ago
a hospital was bombed and it was
immediately well I'm going to tell you
what I think Hamas immediately tell the
world it was an Israeli airri
and that 500 people were killed and that
the hospital had been destroyed and then
as the next couple of days go by the
hospital is relatively undamaged the car
park was
obliterated many fewer people than 500
were killed how many people died we
don't know because actually we're riing
on the Palestinian health authority
which is Hamas in Gaza for the figures
so we don't know the number but a lot
fewer people died it would appear than
the 5
we don't know 50 either way it's
appalling but it may not have been
anywhere near as appalling as was first
said by Hamas but here's the point most
independent studies of what happened
have concluded that it was almost
certainly a militant stroke terror group
inside Gaza and they fired a rocket
which landed in the hospital car park
and other words it wasn't an Israeli air
strike so I have an issue with that
because for three days before for the
attack the priest and the patriarch of
the hospital because it called the the
Baptist Hospital said that they have
received warning multip warning from
Israel that they're going to hit the
hospital and then at the time of the hit
of the hospital one of the top AIDS of
Netanyahu he tweeted about like we hit
the hospital and then he deleted it and
then basically like Israel Gaz lighted
the world most that's why I said most
independent no that's not true New York
Times actually like just published
something to prove that it was shot from
Israel and I think it's they didn't okay
numbers numbers that's not true okay the
New York Times has not reported that it
was Israel no they said the they haven't
okay that's not true over 10 years
Hamas launched 35,000 Rockets into
Israel how many failed they killed 69
people and uh 25% military only part of
them were civilians so over 10 years of
35,000 Rockets they killed 69 people
but in one strike you want to tell me
that these glorified
firecrackers cause that kind of damage
uh yes it looks like they did yeah okay
yeah we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike bra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening up Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know I love about t
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech writing for
R she I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of boozed up Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you and we're
just asking patients to be patient with
us are we only going to be trusting
sources like meta and Google and
Facebook and X formly known as Twitter
where is our where is our unbiased news
going to come for Welcome to the talk
it's really great to be back my little
dar
kids think all they have to do is stay
at home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tok then
yeah problem solve there you go who's
fit as a butchest dog him all right but
but he's now middle class three us here
I nearly have empathy when I'm speaking
to them I know know you're probably
going to boot me off show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for
living
got former PMS all over the joint saying
things the last few days we have indeed
yeah great first show you having fun oh
a ton of fun King PE and King Cube I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're
King FK when I say I am God you think
I'm joking or not you tell me I'm not
joking I'd rather do it on camera no no
no no if it's on camera we're not doing
an interview why we'll explain why how
do you feel about that influence that
you had you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
about Maring Nation yes I'm going to do
you're going to resign I'm going I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV so the question again comes this and
and so far you've ducked it so I want to
ask you one more
time we can both agree that the scenes
in Gaza right now are horrific because I
do feel that but I don't know how else
Israel can eradicate Hamas than the way
that they're currently trying to do it
do you have an alternative for them well
again we are locked in the same thing
what can we do now but we don't look at
what was happening over there you the
best recruiter for Hamas is
Israel I mean you have talked a lot
about the horrible condition in Gaza I
mean let's imagine like a little boy
called Ramy he lives in Gaza you know he
have a horrible life but like you know
it's like it's not that bad I know he
has a cousin in the West Bank he's
living a good life he wake up in the
morning and he found out that he was
kidnapped by three settlers he was
burned alive by curine and he was forced
to drink the kerosene his name is
Muhammad Abu that sers did that to him
in 2016 all right you know what I'm just
going to leave is I'm going to find find
a way to go to Europe his aunt is an a
published offer and she won a prize in
the Frankfurt book fair his name is AD
and now she was cancelled because of
what's happened just because of her a
Palestinian his other aunt in America
his
name she is a speech therapist and I
this is close to my heart because of my
son and she was uh fired because she did
not want to sign the for government cont
said that you cannot join BDS which I
don't understand why do people choosing
to protest peacefully by not buying
goods from a certain country why would
the United States make that its own
issue so and this guy this this Ramy is
being approached by join ham join us
let's go kill is no no no no I don't
want to kill I just I'm going to live in
Gaza it's a life but 97% of water is not
good for human half of the population
are anemic even the is not being treated
and it goes into the shores of Israel
like oh those horrible so and then he
and he wakes up in the morning he
doesn't think about killing Jews the
first thing in the morning he thinks
about being there at 5:00 at the first
50 people in the line for bread because
if he doesn't he will miss the food for
his family and he goes back and he finds
a message saying that we are going to
bomb your house he comes back he loses
his old family now tell me what is a
proportionate response for that I don't
know I don't know you cannot create
terrorism and then you
you have they have created this would I
don't I don't know as the answer but bam
let me ask you this Hamas will have
known when they perpetrated what they
did on October the 7th what the scale of
response was likely to be how does that
help the Palestinian people they are
supposed to serve I don't know the
wheels are already set in motion but it
doesn't does it I do not you know here's
the thing I feel sometimes that Hames is
with us in the room that we are bringing
Hamas who has the power in this equation
who has the fourth largest and strongest
military power the whole idea about
Israel is like oh my God we are the
Arabs are going to destroy us look at
the map hang on let me hang on hamas's
stated goal is the eradication yeah of
Israel and the Jewish people yes they
make no pretense about it they've made
no attempt unlike the Nazis who try to
cover up their crimes they've made no
attempt to try and deny they brazenly
boasted about it they are proud of what
they did right and they will have known
again that the scale of what they did in
October the 7th would have prompted this
kind of response which would have led to
thousands of innocent Palestinians
getting killed and my question for you I
wish the 7th of October never happened
right every time every time something
you say Hamas is everywhere well yeah
actually all roads all roads on this
particular part of the crisis and I
accept it's been going on for 75 years
this conflict but all roads in this
crisis lead to Hamas and what they did
and and not necessarily because because
all roads goes to the condition that
created Hamas if the if the Jewish
people were expelled from Europe and
went to Argentina or South Africa and
Uganda and went in and took the land you
would have ham all you and I can agree
that the conditions Palestinian people
have had to endure in Gaza for a very
long time are completely unacceptable I
think it's completely unacceptable that
Israel has wielded such control over the
people of G
working out who can come in and who can
go out turning on and off Water and
Power on a whim turning off the internet
on and off at a whim all that kind of
stuff I can completely agree with but
given that I think we agree Hamas are a
terror group let's say let me finish my
question given that we agree that Hamas
is a terror organization who have a
publicly stated position of annihilating
not just Israel but Jewish people and as
we saw on October the 7th they mean it
if you are is Israel what do you do to
get rid of those people who have shown
the world that's exactly what they will
actually do if they get the chance you
know what I would
do I would give the Palestinians what
they
deserve terrorism is a virus yes it's a
virus I agree if a patient with a flu
came to you and you're a doctor how can
you treat that
patient how do you treat as a doctor how
do you do well you're the doctor you
give them nutrition yeah fluids and rest
so the immunity of the body gets rid of
the virus on its own M if I received
that patient with a flu and I took a
sledam I like why are you not getting
better do you think that patient will
get better no you are weakening him you
are making him worse I think if you have
two groups of people who are
ideologically wedded to your destruction
as a state and as a populace and you're
constantly firing Rockets as mass have
done for over decade now then that
cannot be acceptable you have to stop
that right these are terrorists who've
now shown on October the 7th their true
colors they don't just talk about
wanting to kill all Jewish people they
are going to do it if they get the
chance so I don't believe Hamas can
possibly stay in any position of
authority in Gaza I think that would be
ruinous for not just the people of Gaza
but also for Israelis so if you're going
to get rid of them which many people
think on both sides is is inevitable and
should happen as a consequence of what
they did the big question is how do you
do that and I don't know any other way
other than the way Israel is currently
doing hence my personal moral quandry
about this so if a terrorist takes over
the Empire State instead of taking him
out we bomb the whole empire state well
that's the question isn't it proportion
that is not even a question that was not
even a question because that would be
ridiculous you talk about you talk about
the normalization of the region I mean
the theory that I most buy into support
Ed by recent I think Wall Street Journal
reporting that hundreds of Hamas
terrorists had gone to Iran for training
before this attack it obviously been
very carefully organized and so that is
I think highly likely but if you're Iran
and you're looking at all this
normalization and you're looking at
Saudi Arabia being next this is your
worst nightmare so a perfect time to
commit an atrocity like this through
your proxy of Hamas again I'm not a
political expert to know what is the
background but let me tell you theory is
Hamas justifi is all of the horrible
conditions that Palestinians are living
in is that a justification for Hamas
doing what they did good do you think so
of course not right so we're agreed no
of course and it may well be here by the
way as I've said that if Israel pursues
this ground Invasion it backfires
horribly it leads to a much wider
conflict involving many other people
possibly including Iran directly and it
could be a horrendous escalation and a
massive war raging through the whole
region and that is my fear about it but
I come back to the central point of
justification and I'm really struggling
to see what else Israel is supposed to
do to get rid of Hass and if you've got
an
alternative let's hear it I do Pierce
this is never about Hamas believe me it
is never about hes if somebody tells you
who they are
listen is has been telling the world all
the time they need to clear the gaza's
STP into Egypt you think that's always
been the plan always there I mean they
have said it they have said it many
times why does why does Egypt take them
and do you think when Egypt takes them
do you think they go back no never and
then when they're done with Gaza they
will go back to the West Bank they will
kind of like build the settlements
around them and then until they push
them into Jordan because that is the
plan they have talken not just benam
everybody so like there's no state two
state it is one state and is for the Jew
I don't think he believes in a two-state
solution nobody believes in a two- State
solution
[Applause]
[Music]
e
okay let's let's move forward oh yeah
let's let's assume somehow we get to a
place possibly at the instigation of
countries like Sou Arabia and others
getting directly involved where you get
to a place where Hamas are removed and I
don't quite see how that happens without
enormous further Bloodshed but let's
assume they get removed let's assume
that Netanyahu is removed from office
which I think is highly likely just from
the fury of his own people about what
they see as the defensive and security
failings plus his attack on the Supreme
Court already causing huge polarization
let's assume we get new leadership in
both
places could there still be peace could
there still
no because Israel have already shown
it's not about Nyah it is the policy of
Israel not to give the Palestinian their
seat it has always been there but what
if you find leadership that understands
you will not but why why are you so not
do you not see there's any chance of
doing that here no not with Israel Obama
after he left office he wrote in his
book The problem with the Palestinian
Israeli conflict is that that one side
is extremely powerful and one side is
extremely weak there is absolutely
nothing to oblige that strong side to
give anything all over the years Israel
showed you many times that they are not
interested in peace leave Gaza forget
Hamas for a second the West Bank what
have they been doing in the West Bank
the illegal settlements did not stop a
single day are and it's completely wrong
yeah yeah yeah but but but the thing
wrong but you see what they're doing in
the West Bank right now they are
creating little gas they are creating
little gas yeah and until they like
squeeze them there was there and it's
completely wrong there is a hilarious
documentary called The Wanted 18 it is
like an Israeli Palestinian
co-production and it tells about the
incredible story about the residence of
bahur it's a Palestinian town next to
the na and uh they said they don't want
to depend on the milk coming from the
kaputs so they bought 18 cows 18 cows
and they didn't know how to milk the
cows or we have a a cow farm so so they
were like engineers and and and doctors
they send people to kind of like to
learn how to do the farm so they bought
the cows and they started to produce
milk and they started to sell the milk
to The Villages the Israeli authorities
were not very comfortable so one day the
military government came in us like
those cows and I quote constitutes an
exis threat to the National Security of
the state of Israel you need to get rid
of them and the movie goes about like
the hilarious attempts of hiding those
cows between The Butchers and the houses
and in one scene that a cow is actually
running and the the Israeli soldiers are
like running behind it and they corner
it and they corner it and they about to
kill it and you know what did the cow
say you didn't fall for this cows don't
speak yeah but you know it actually said
something you know what did it say it
said but
anyways but you see this is the
ideology of the
Israeli ruling but they are not
interested they're not even allowing you
to get your own cows but this comes back
to what you were saying at the start
which is about the hate on both sides no
no no I'm not talking about the hate on
I'm talking about this shining example
that Israel W tell the that we are like
the Western World we are secular I don't
know if you know this but they're not
just like secular like RAC against their
own Arab I'm talking about like Arabs
with Palestinian with Israeli identity
I'm talking about them being even racist
against their own people 1950 Yemen's
immigrants that came from Yemen and they
were in the transition Camp waiting to
be transformed into Israel their kids
were taken away from them and given to
White Ashkenazi Jews because they were
not white enough but Bon what would
happen if a Jewish person went to Gaza
how can why would they go to G and
exactly even I wouldn't go to G exactly
that's my point yeah it's a dystopia who
but like but I'm just it's not just
raising points about Israel making out
that somehow there is bad or Worse
what's going on there
the pales inessive way imag absolutely
but you know what Hamas never claimed
that they are the only democracy in the
in the in the region they never claim
that they are secular they never said
that they adopt Western CH and they
definitely definitely they did not use
that lie in order to car to bom a whole
country now here I want to one example
and I'm going to leave you Israel you
think that Israel will like by the way
the whole thing about the many children
you can find it in New York Times it's
called like the uh the Lost Children of
Israel
the Forgotten uh but even when Ethiopian
people were immigrated to Israel
Ethiopian
Jews women then Report 2013 that's is
not like 50 years ago they reported that
they were given against their consent
and without their knowledge
contraceptive shots so they wouldn't
reproduce because they are the wrong
color Israel is is a
racist apartheid country that is
projecting this shiny example of
secularism and democracy for the people
so people can accept whatever they do
because they look at Palestinians as
lesser people this is the whole point
this is the whole point and I would like
to quote Winston
Churchill he had a quote that say I
don't believe that we have made a great
wrong to the red Indians of America or
the black people of Australia because
they were replaced by a higher race a
stronger race a more World wisely race
this is this is why why Queen R is
criticizing the West this is why we here
said like where are your values because
this is the Crux of the problem it's not
Hamas it's not Palestine it is people
looking at us as lesser human beings b i
and I don't dispute the characterization
that a lot of the Israel Administration
look upon Palestinians as lesser people
otherwise they wouldn't they even look
at Jews and Y Jews Like Les I wouldn't
dispute that um I want to quote you
to end this no why would you end this
don't end this we'll be talking for two
hours why not at some point amazing time
do another interview well this one goes
big um I think this is a neat way to end
it he said I actually believe there is a
middle ground between everybody and they
can meet I direct my criticism for the
extreme of each one of them that was you
Bassam youf m i I agree with that but I
don't share your view there can never be
peace in this region I think they can't
be with the current leadership
structures in both countries or both
places but I definitely think you've got
to be optimistic about peace you just
need to find people for it I hope so but
the reason
listen I refused to come on my on your
show when your producer first called me
for the first
interview because I was scared I was
afraid for me that was a career
suicide because and
and I have I'm talk this is even
important because you are someone who's
always talked about like against cancel
about like talking speaking your mind
out speaking your mind out I left Egypt
and I came to America the land of the
free the home of the brave but I didn't
know that there was a fine print said
that you cannot speak about Israel I
have issue with that Israel is a foreign
country their allies good you speak
about
Israel how many people lost their jobs
even she's she by the way she hasn't
lost her job no no but she talked about
death threats she's talking about like
being silenced by the B is she's
Palestinian and you know who else
sisters I love theth they are with us
yeah anyway so I know them both are very
nice people yeah but but the thing is if
if you are that high and you cannot
speak about it and it's not about well
you can you just have to yeah you can I
mean I've spoken out about these issues
and you get shot at not literally but
metaphorically all day long on social
media
that shouldn't stop people from doing it
I'm just like wondering as an as an
American yeah but I I'm doing now
because like the first interview went
well I'm doing that because I want
people to see that you can really speak
up and not just get canceled but get
rewarded my career is going fine yeah
it's great because I want people to have
the courage why are there should be no
limits I'm I'm I'm kind of like so so
confused as an American citizen why
every American president cand
presidential candidate have to go and
kiss the hand and bend the knees to
APAC this is a Lobby that works for a
foreign country interest why don't we
have like a Lobby for Saudi Arabia at is
they giving us more money you know the
great thing you can say that here yes
you couldn't say in Egypt that's why
you're living here yes but again a lot
of people feel the burn the heat
whenever they come but if I was an
American I'd be going all right bassim
all right we'll take the criticism
because you can do that in this country
and I'm happy when you criticize the
government in your own country yeah they
drove you out yes and that's why I came
to America to play The White Man's game
to actually to to to pass this acquired
white privilege to my children but the
problem it's not just a country of white
people but here's the problem and the
white man's game the the game in America
is not a white man's game it's a game
that actually has a democracy and
believes in Freedom of spee there dog
whistles everywhere you're not going to
be put in jail for this interview or I
can lose my career and I can lose jobs
and you know that you couldn't in Egypt
you could no here you Egypt they
arrested you here you and they
threatened you and you would have ended
up in prison or dead here a lot of
people lost their jobs because they
spoke up it depends what they say of
course but again if you're cany West and
you spew anti-semitic
I'm I will never adopt that kind of
point of view but the thing is there is
dog whistles everywhere as I told you at
the beginning you cannot just say like
antiem an like I mean now the how come
that the Palestinian flag is outload by
the way it's outload in Israel if you
raise the a you go to jail and now
they're saying like the Palestinian flag
is a pramas no it's not a pramas you
know I was in I was doing a comedy show
in Arizona and a guy was like wearing
like a cof like a scarf and I took it
and and I'm not like in Hyperbole and
like wearing symbols but I just want
because like why are we are we going to
Outlook colors and flags that is that
that is absurd that is not right I don't
I agree I don't think you should but you
should certainly Outlaw Hamas regard
they're already Outlaw I mean I'm not
supporting teror group okay okay but the
people with the power the people who
supposedly have the and you should by
the way I will say this you should be
able to criticize Israeli government
without being accused of being
anti-semitic I have in this interview
repeatedly and I'm not anti-semitic I
just have a problem with a lot of what
the Israeli government's been doing and
I have a problem with how any criticism
to Israel by some circles here are
considered anti-semite this is not fair
yeah but a lot of the people doing it
are actually anti-semitic yes but also a
lot of zionists are against Israel that
they HTE the Jews you know it it it
we've discussed that I want to end on a
happy but before I want to just like say
two words about the media which is
please
sure uh Mr zlot the Palestinian ambass
that you have this guy lost six members
of his family in an Israeli
strike and when he went on like some
British news thing he sat down and and
and and and the lady told him like we
are very sorry for personal f I'm sure
you don't condem the killing of Israeli
civilians what in the same moment
there's another girl like called diara
Aid she was like on Sky News and and the
girl was like cry like I lost 30 members
of my family 17 of them are children I
lost my best friend I and then what do
you think would happen
is forget about empathy a lot of people
what about manners well I think you have
to stop I've said this repeatedly you
have to start from a place of humanity
you have to look at what happened on
October the 7th and feel utterly
outraged and disgusted for the loss of
human life and you also have to feel
that for what's happening in Gaza to
innocent people and if you don't if you
can't feel both for both sets of people
both sets of innocent people being
killed if you can't feel a sense of of
Despair and horror over their death you
don't have any Humanity believe me
Pierce believe me Pierce it's not really
about that there's a deep sentiment in
the Middle East in Arabs that the West
do not look at us as equals well you
know what so what I did I went to the
machines yeah and I asked Chad gbt
simple
questions do Israelis deserve to be free
and you know what they tell me yes
israelies deserve the right like any
other people and then I asked the same
question do Palestinians deserve to be
free and you know what they tell me it
is complex it is a sensitive issue well
it's not complex it's not sensitive the
Palestinian people should be free yeah
but the ma be finished and they should
have exactly the same rights to freedom
and freedom of expression and a way to
lead their lives and to water and to
power and to Internet that Israelis have
and we have here in America and we have
back in my home country of the UK and I
want that for the Palestinian people
we've got to end it there okay mainly
because I've worked up a hell of a
hunger in two hours of interview and you
have brought your wife's cooking holler
so tell me again how I do this okay so
basically take a piece of this put it in
the olive oil yes which is from the West
Bank yeah from the west bank and then a
little bit of this yes are that yes yes
this is like amazing oil coming from the
Olive Tree uh this is come from the West
Bank since 1967 Israel have actually
uprooted 800,000 Olive Tree just to that
is absolutely delicious I know please
thank your wife for me thank you wish
her all the best and her family
particularly those who are obviously in
Gaza it's been great to see you thank
you so much in America let's do it again
let's do it again let's keep talking
honestly think the way through this is
people keep talking yes good to see
thank you so
[Music]
much we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and you face just stared
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
toour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech for I'm so
rich frankly I'm going to take the side
of boozed up Brits against these pomp
you mean you're not going to support
mayor Jose
L stop pying to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid consults don't really know
what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're in
IND dated we are really working